en fait c'était une demande d'une
émission qui s'appelle le grand oral et
en fait le thème des de la finale du
concours c'était une déclaration d'avoir
la France justement j'ai du coup écrit
cette chanson qui comme l'histoire
la légende le raconte a été coupée au
montage pour des raisons obscures
quand on a commencé à travailler
ensemble elle a elle a déjà eu des
épisodes de chroniques radio qui ou les
gars ont commencé à la censurer on
commençait à la rappeler pour lui dire
mais non ça faut l'enlever ni gnagnagna
ça me rendait fou
rendez fou ça m'en est fou et encore
jusqu'à maintenant c'est à dire que
maintenant c'est quand même l'une des
plus grosses vendeuses de tickets en
France et non mais il m'avait dit
justement on vient de chercher parce
qu'on adore cet humour là et donc quand
je leur ai envoyé la chanson
ils m'ont dit bah on adore mais il
faudrait enlever ce mot là il faudrait
faudrait pas dire ça est-ce que tu peux
adapter un petit peu donc du coup on a
dit non
si tu vas pas à fond dans cet humour là
finalement l'effet il est raté parce que
on a l'impression que que tu as peur de
dire des trucs donc ils nous ont demandé
je crois au début d'enlever plus de
et
oui mais si j'enlève plus de pupuce
qu'est-ce que je vais dire je vais pas
dire péripatéticienne moi ça m'a pas de
sens
passe dessus dans tous les sens à chaque
minute délire ma mère et Mac en
profondeur 8 millions de touristes par
mois ça en fait des bus de chinois de la
tourelle c'est la sainte robe la France
et la de l'Europe
finalement donc on a dit non on garde la
chanson telle et ils ont dit bon bah
d'accord et ils ont coupé au montage le
problème c'est qu'elle met tellement
d'énergie de temps quand elle écrit une
chronique une chanson un sketch elle
peut vraiment rester devant une page
pendant des heures à retravailler une
phrase donc si tu veux quand tu passes
autant de temps sur quelque chose
pour en ressortir un travail qui est
balayé d'un coup de stylo franchement
c'est compliqué et ça rend fou ça
m'étonne en fait c'est pas ça c'est que
je commence à être blasé qu'on me coupe
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas grave
c'est que maintenant quand je fais une
émission je dis toute façon ils vont
couper donc au final maintenant que j'ai
mes réseaux sociaux c'est cool parce que
j'ai un lien direct avec mon public et
j'ai pas forcément besoin d'être en télé
ou en radio pour me faire connaître donc
je me dis bon tant pis je ferai ça sur
sur mes réseaux et puis voilà elle aura
elle les a bien quand même deux
trois fois parce que parce que le
problème c'est que maintenant quand tu
lui sens sur quelque chose elle te dit
ah tu me le censure elle va se mettre
devant sa caméra puis elle dit voilà ce
qui m'a été censuré